now then it's time for me to make the
donuts the English dub of dragon ball
super has finally come to completion 18
months after the original Japanese
finale did and people wonder why I
didn't wait for the English dub of
dragon ball now before I get into
anything here I want to make one thing
clear I grew up with the English dubbing
of the show and I am a fan of both the
original Japanese and Funimation's
production for different reasons I think
both offer their own strengths and I can
understand why someone might prefer one
over the other however today I want to
find out which one you guys prefer
earlier this week I sent out a tweet
asking my followers this with English
dub of dragon ball super having come to
completion what are some scenes you
thought they did really well today I
will be taking the best scenes as
recommended by you the audience and I
will be asking you guys who did it
better
Funimation or to--a the English dub or
the Japanese
[Music]
before a jump into this headfirst I want
to quickly touch on a few things that
the English dub has done to push fans
away from their version and to be
perfectly honest it has nothing to do
with the performances really across the
board I think it's safe to say everyone
delivered some spectacular renditions of
the characters what has drawn some
criticism from the fanbase firstly has
been how their home releases have looked
distinctly greener than the broadcast
versions we first saw honestly I'm
really at a loss as to why this green
tint is present in a lot of these
releases from Funimation even in the
classic Dragon Ball film reviews I do my
editor oftentimes corrects the visuals
to be more satisfying result however
that's not even the Funimation dubs
biggest drawback for some reason once
the turn into power cut under way the
Toonami release of Dragon Ball super had
massive framerate issues during its
broadcast during scenes of high action
or high frame count tsunamis Dragon Ball
super episodes would stutter and chop in
a distracting fashion when compared with
the smoother undoctored version however
the interesting part with this was that
all this chopping and dropped frames was
intentional apparently due to some
strict regulations in the United States
no less two nominees very own Jason
DeMarco even went on to explain this on
Twitter he said so remember the Pokemon
flashing episode that triggered a bunch
of epileptic episodes and viewers since
then TV networks have something called
the Harding test every show commercial
etc is run through this test to make
sure it doesn't have flashing frames
that could trigger folks with epilepsy
the last few episodes of Dragon Ball
super have had fight scenes that are cut
to about one frame per adit in some
places which means they eventually
failed the Harding test however he does
go on to say our program edit folks who
do these tests normally just slow the
cuts down in these scenes to about four
frames per second in the case of these
Dragon Ball super episodes it made the
fight scenes look insanely slow program
edits do this routinely so they didn't
even think to notify us thanks to you
fans who let me know we asked prog edit
if there was any way they could slow
these scenes down less so from now on
they will be slowed if they failed the
test to two frames a second down from
one we tested it and it looks way better
this is honestly a really interesting
piece of legislation as the first time
I've seen something like this brought to
my attention since I found out about
that one Pokemon episode that was pulled
back in the day and to be honest I don't
know what other
because they have in other countries
what I do know is the result looks sort
of trash but at least the intentions
were good and efforts were made to
rectify the issue not that it matters
anymore with the show being over so
let's dive in
[Music]
almost two years ago to this day I
uploaded a video talking about Dragon
Ball super English dub when I uploaded
that diss had only just happened so with
it sort of being my two year anniversary
on this topic I think this is a great
place to start when I asked you guys on
Twitter to recommend scenes for me to
check out this was one of the only ones
prior to the Future Trunks arc that was
mentioned time and again and honestly I
think that's for a good reason the first
three arcs are largely bad with some
gems here and there but it really wasn't
setting the world on fire this scene
however absolutely did both when it was
released in Japan and in the West this
might be one of the more divisive scenes
as Sean's performance here with his
screams are honestly throat shredding li
effective which is fitting I think
seeing as the Kaioken technique is super
stressful on the body however I adore
the original and honestly it's hard to
beat
both of these offer extremely different
versions that I'm excited to see which
ones you prefer in the comment section
[Applause]
this one was by far the most highly
recommended English dub Goku scene and I
can see why then again if you're not a
fan of shown Chimel delivery then this
won't do you any favors and is exactly
what fans of the Japanese hate the Goku
black arc offered a lot in the way of
variety for Sean as he delivered Lions
for Goku Goku black and British Goku but
this scene here is as classic Dragon
Ball in the West as it gets this is a
scene that is right in Sean shrivels
classic toolbox and it sounds exactly
how you'd imagine pretty darn good so
let's compare
you're gonna regret telling me that
sauna suit does know I'm mad I'm really
really mad
and now it's time to be mother Costa
both Nozawa and Shawn nailed this scene
and honestly this entire arc - Britt
British Goku but even that was rectified
somewhat later on both of these actors
show great versatility with the
portrayal of these characters and it was
honestly terrific to watch to be
perfectly honest a lot of what was
recommended for Goku were these big
action set pieces and really these are
just more screams and speeches so let's
look at something a little more subdued
and different leave it to the biggest
villain in the universe to exploit my
biggest weakness you know me too well
this was my favorite scene in Dragon
Ball super not a fight not a speech not
even a plot twist my favorite scene was
a conversation between Goku and Frieza
and I was surprised to see that the
English and Japanese interpretations
differed somewhat not necessarily in
what they say but in how they say it I
first saw this scene in the original
Japanese years ago and what I loved most
about it was Nizam's clear change in
mood and tone as she spoke through Goku
to begin the interaction Nozawa delivers
the lines as if Goku is holding his
cards close to his chest it's as if we
were seeing Goku as intellectual as he
truly is he knows exactly what Frieza is
like and can afford to make no mistakes
around him her delivery is Kam firm and
you could hear the compromising Goku's
voice through her delivery as he
attempts to play this verbal mind game
with Frieza
okay
[Music]
oco-2 our Xterra Kumari masa de una foto
aricema
[Music]
Oh
it's one of the most nuanced
performances I've seen from her and I
honestly was blown away by it
nozawa totally knocked it out of the
park there's a reason she's one of the
highest paid actors in Japan
Shawn's performance on the other hand
while not bad doesn't offer the same
emotional depth or at least not the same
emotional depth that I read from the
scene originally his Goku sounds more
standard in his response and always at
least to me sounds like he's on the
losing side of the discussion
nozawa never sounded like she was on the
losing side with exhilaration so you win
will you be also disappointed if I
decline well then in that case I decline
[Music]
again this performance is fine from
Shawn and is in line with what he's
delivered so far but I personally think
the emotional depth was more apparent
with misawa's Japanese original however
with that said depending on what you
like about Goku there seems to be pros
and cons to both performers
interpretations of the character so
here's your chance click the top right
to cast your vote on which
interpretation you thought was best
Masako Nozawa or Shawn shimmer while the
scene was my favorite I'd be lying if I
said Goku was the only reason this scene
worked for me
Frieza was spectacular - and speaking of
Frieza and Goku the sponsor of today's
video is this drawing I did of Goku and
Frieza a few weeks back I made this
video where I drew a different cover for
the game Dragon Ball Z Kakarot and so
many people liked it it inspired me to
sell it as a poster it's my very first
piece of merch and artwork for sale this
will be available for a limited time
only so if you would like to buy this
poster to love and to hold to caress
lovingly on your wall follow the link in
the description to grab your piece of
artwork today and now back to Frieza
both interpretations of Frieza
are honestly spectacular and what's more
is the English voice supplied by the
incredibly talented Chris Aires is a
spot-on interpretation of the character
when looked alongside the Japanese
version by overuse aina cow listen to
the contempt in Chris's English voice
when he says the name beerus you don't
to have everything go your way forever
beerus this serves two purposes the
first is obviously to communicate his
disdain for beerus but it is also to
communicate something that is less
obvious in English listen to the
Japanese version and I'll explain what I
mean needs my demos got the same a thing
beetus in the japanese version when he
says beerus his name he does so in a way
that communicates disrespect in japanese
if you go back to watch freezes
interaction with beerus he always says
beerus sama the sama suffix act as a
sign of respect in the Japanese language
and culture the person including the
sama suffix acknowledges the named
person's position of authority above
them this is a similar principle to when
goku added the suffix chan to Zeno
calling him zen-chan this is a super
informal way of referring to someone and
is usually reserved for close friends of
the same social standing which is why
beerus sort of freaked out when goku
called him that the japanese versions
removal of the sama suffix from Frieza -
beerus communicates not only disdain but
massive disrespect also and i think
chris ayers communicates that disrespect
very well through tone to make up for
the english languages inability to
communicate that exact linguistic
japanese quirk do you actually believe
you're fit to be a god well i'll destroy
the destroyer you'll make a fine trophy
for my case while Frieza had a number of
terrific moments in the tournament of
power one that particularly stood out to
me in the English and the Japanese was
this
[Music]
I love this scene as it shows an
interesting new side to Frieza but the
English version decided to sprinkle
something else in subtly this is
honestly easily missed but I adored that
they scripted this interaction such that
Frieza
doesn't refer to Goku as a monkey but
instead as a Saiyan I wouldn't say that
this was a moment of respect but more a
moment of non bigoted racist hatred for
him and his race needless to say this
was an elegant way of communicating
freezes mindset during this particular
interaction and Chris absolutely nailed
it as always that said I read in like
the scripting for Goku as he launches
Frieza
first we'll play the Japanese version of
this scene and then we'll play the
English version for comparison
[Music]
did you hear show and say alley-oop I
did I can't stop hearing it now I
wouldn't say that this was Sean's idea I
mean it could have been but it more than
likely falls under the scripting
Department regardless I thought that
this light-hearted line took from the
overall tension the scene was going for
but that's enough a Goku time to vote
for which version of Frieza you thought
did it best was it Chris Aires or was it
what do you say in the cow kick the top
right and cast your vote is that
supposed to be insulting you say I'm
arrogant I say damn right that's cry
pride in the saying I am the mighty
Prince of the ultimate warrior race it's
hard to make a video discussing dragon
ball without mentioning Vegeta's name in
Dragon Ball super his character can be
seen as sharing the position of main
character with Goku in some respects so
let's take a look
Christopher Sabbath the voice of Aegina
in the English dub is a fan of the
series and I honestly really enjoy his
Vegeta specifically in moments where he
brought comedy to the equation now I get
it
you're feeling jealous aren't you a
charming and dignified alien going to
lunch all alone with your beautiful
bride no I don't give a damn about that
you can at least protect yeah sure fine
babies beerus here on the other hand
many fans love the Gina for his epic
speeches and screams so let's compare
those with the original
[Music]
[Applause]
in addition to this there's a terrific
scene towards the end of the series in
episode 129 where Vegeta finds himself
talking down to Bell mode and hyping up
Goku in his final moments the one time
Vegeta finds himself trash-talking a
clown and he doesn't call him a clown
how do these writers get paid I mean
like if the joke is sitting there now
before moving on I want to highlight my
favorite Vegeta moment from the English
dub growing up my first impression of
the character was through Bryan
Drummond's ocean dub performance so when
the opportunity came for there to be a
copy Vegeta Funimation had the ingenious
idea to have that character voiced by
Bryan Drummond I was beyond happy to see
that voice in modern Dragonball again
and it was a really cool inclusion for
longtime fans with that said which
Vegeta do you think was better the
Japanese or the English interpretation
vote now this has been a long video with
a lot of different comparisons so I
think now is the perfect time to ask you
guys for one last final vote which dub
did you prefer the English or the
Japanese click here overall I think the
age of the English dub being heralded as
a subpar production has passed there's
clearly a lot of love and attention for
the franchise being put into this
dubbing production
there aren't any massive line flubs that
change the scenes like they did back in
the day and the moments of comedy land
really well for English audiences with
Western sensibilities with that said the
English version of ultimate battle
really misses the mark I think in this
video I only touched on three characters
and who knows I might look at more in
the future but for now this is how I
feel about the English dub of Dragon
Ball super
there's some clever scripting not so
clever scripting passionate deliveries
and high production values if you
haven't taken a look it's definitely
worth a watch leave a comment down below
letting everyone know what you thought
subscribe for more videos like this and
don't forget to leave a like or dislike
I'll see you all in the next video thank
you so much for watching
[Music]